a funeral cortege makes its way through
the baked dry and dusty farmlands of
northeastern Syria we're on the border
with Turkey well within range of their
guns
it's a convoy of civilians and Kurdish
militia fighters the YPG tradition
dictates the Fallen should be laid to
rest in the village of their birth if
it's possible at the cemetery the bodies
of the two men are taken by their
families and frightened comments Joanne
chello was a seven-year veteran the Fort
Islamic state alongside the United
States Special Forces but he died in the
border town of Duras here killed by the
NATO ally of Turkey there's pain and
anguish as you'd expect at any funeral
but there is anger here as well all of
these people feel betrayed by the United
States
[Music]
they expected nothing more from Turkey
they've been waiting for it for being
abandoned by the USA is to them the last
straw as we filmed a small but angry
group gathered around us asking if we
were Americans they accepted we weren't
but told us to leave something that's
never happened to me here suddenly
border towns big town's are emptying of
people the attacks from the Turkish guns
are doing the job its government wants
to flush out the Kurds from their homes
along hundreds of miles of border it can
be called many things but it's being
cleansed tens of thousands are on the
move
Dobis air has been attacked constantly
they can't resist this look how near
Turkey and its military are the few who
are left are taking what they can
emptying homes and shops this man tells
me he has no choice but to take his
family to safety but he insists he's
coming back and he said is that the same
with all the men is that they they're
looking after the families and we'll all
come
yeah yes listen he's not going to come
back together and then how are you how
are you how is this pipe feeling is he
okay yeah Thursday at another see she
says she's scared the men may be
returning it's impossible to know if
their families ever will but nobody here
will forget this moment and a sign of
how dangerous this is becoming a car
bomb in a city of Qamishli the effective
regional candidate there been missile
attacks from Turkey but this is now
being claimed by Islamic state there are
thousands of them here
many imprisoned right on the border in
reality Turkey's simple buffer zone plan
really isn't that simple at all still
Ramsey Sky News in Northeast Syria